et pour revenir sur la situation en
israël nous sommes avec jacques
benillouche journaliste indépendant
bonjour monsieur benillouche merci
d'être avec nous alors 1re confinement
durci en israël qui doit entrer en
vigueur à 14h aujourd'hui de quel oeil
vous voyez vous les dernières annonces
du gouvernement
alors je voudrais dire d'abord que cette
épidémie a mis en doute la parole des
scientifiques puisque nous avons un
comité dirigé par un très grand
professeur de médecine qui avait dirigé
lance la plus grand hôpital d'israël et
il n'est pas d'accord du tout avec les
mesures prises par le gouvernement il
estimé qu' on pouvait prendre des
mesures plus réduite
il y avait un conflit devant imposés 7
mais pas à ce niveau là
ils estiment effectivement que les
mesures sont trop drastiques
vous savez c'est un gros problème en
israël nous avons les que des petits
centres commerciaux qui vivent de la
population locale et si l'on ferme la
totalité de ses cendres eh bien c'est la
vie qui s'arrête c'est le chômage qui
augmente c'est les jeunes qui sont en
difficulté et c'est pour ça qu'on
comprend que il y ait une grande
différence
un genre de panique entre le
gouvernement et le professeur rosny
gamzou qui est justement le grand bâton
de ce comité du corps d'un virus alors
on pourrait dire que c'est normal parce
qu'il y avait une grosse grosse épidémie
mais on estime qu' on aurait pu un jour
dans mon centre nous avons un petit
centre commercial à mes côtés eh bien on
aurait pu quand même permettre à
certains commerces de fonctionner avec
une ou deux personnes à l'intérieur ça
cet effet au début de la crise on l'aimé
mais les boutiques et avait mis une
barrière une personne ne rentre dans
chaque magasin
on a fermé totalement les restaurants on
a fermé totalement les les cafés ans et
la vie du pays qui est en cause or je
rentre à peine 2 de paris et j'ai vu
qu'à paris on avait trouvé des solutions
innovantes les les terrasses de café
cheveux
sont installés dans la rue sur les
parkings des voitures et ça a permis de
donner un peu de vie produit et surtout
un peu d'oxygène à ces centres à ces
restaurateurs et à ce débat alors on
sait justement pourquoi la population
n'est pas très contente c'est qu'on sait
pourquoi il y a eu une crise qui a
augmenté et crise du corona qui a
augmenté c'est qu'il ya certains centres
certaines régions certains quartiers de
certaines villes qui sont en danger
ces quartiers malheureusement la plupart
de ces quartiers sont occupés par des
religieux orthodoxes qui ne respectent
pas les mesures sanitaires de porter des
masques par exemple eh bien on aurait pu
faire un genre de blocage de ces de ces
quartiers
mais seulement s'il ya un problème
politique qui se posent les fiches
justement il ya beaucoup de critiques de
la part de l'opposition
les opposants au gouvernement netanyahou
accuse justement le premier ministre de
durcir le confinement pour affaiblir les
manifestations qui sont devenus très
récurrentes et qui ont lieu pratiquement
toutes les semaines
devant sa résidence à jérusalem je vais
citer d'ailleurs un chef de l'opposition
qui déclare la cause de ce profil mans
n'est pas le comique 19 mai la gestion
raté négligente et hystérique du
gouvernement de netanyahou qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
eh bien je pense qu'effectivement il ya
une certaine méthode qui a été utilisé
par le gouvernement pour éteindre un
petit peu le je dirais ces
manifestations presque quotidiennes nous
avons pratiquement les gilet jaune en
dix serait comme vous les avez eue et
bien à l'heure actuelle c'est
pratiquement toutes les semaines tous
les doutes auraient tous les jours que
les manifestations ont lieu devant la
résidence du premier bilan est là les
mesures de confinement ont interdit ces
cmmc ces manifestations ce qui pour
certains une atteinte à la liberté par
la liberté de manifester à la liberté de
contester et donc effectivement orsan
qui a une certaine mesure de la part du
gouvernement des mesures politiques
d'ailleurs je signale un petit détail
qui n'a pas été tellement repris par les
médias c'est que pendant cette période
de confinement il ya deux jours
le gouvernement de netanyahu a décidé de
relancer la construction dans les
implantations de cisjordanie
ça veut dire qu'en fait il ya
effectivement des mesures qu'on peut
prendre et des mesures qu'on ne doit pas
prendre et c'est de là dans ce sens que
nous nous trouvons devant une difficulté
et c'est surtout le fait que nous nous
ne n'écoutons pas nos spécialistes
médicaux qui eux le professeur gamzou à
dire on ne doit pas confiné totalement
il en va il en va de la de l'économie du
pays
or ou qu'on n'écoute pas le professeur
gamzou qui est quand même une sommité au
sein du pays
et c'est pour ça qu'on pense qu'à
l'heure actuelle c'est que des positions
politiques
pourquoi le gouvernement ne ferme pas
certains quartiers de jérusalem certains
quartiers dash donne certains quartiers
de debra qui sont des quartiers
religieux parce que dans ces quartiers
les orthodoxes je refuse de se plier aux
mesures euro ne serait ce que de refuser
c'est qu'israël va célébrer il ya un
petit pour dans deux jours aux experts
rassemblement qui réunit chaque année
des milliers de fidèles
est-ce que vous pensez que les gens vont
voilà vraiment appliquer cette mesure de
confinement généralisé ou est ce que
risque d'une reprise épidémique est à
craindre dans les prochains jours je
dirais dans certains régions laïque je
prends notre cas mon cas tel aviv
eh bien nous respectons totalement
beaucoup genre décidé de ne pas aller
cette année à la synagogue
vous savez que les religieux les non
religieux une fois par an rohff vont
fêter le yom kippour alors c'est sûr que
dans certaines régions laïque et béraud
va rester chez soi on va attendre mais
je crains que dans des régions orthodoxe
on ne tient pas compte de ces mesures et
le gouvernement ne peut rien faire parce
que les rabbins cliff qui participe à la
coalition gouvernementale ont menacé de
démissionner et de faire sauter la
coalition si des mesures étaient prises
contre les orthodoxes contre les
religieux donc nous sommes devant cette
impasse et je ne sais pas comment on va
pouvoir s'en tirer
merci beaucoup en tout cas jacques
benillouche d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste indépendant et vous étiez en
direct group de télé
israël a